el dueño de una pequeña empresa debe
contratar trabajadores por temporada
conforme aumenta la necesidad la
siguiente lista muestra el número de
empleados contratados mensualmente por
un periodo de 5 meses si la media de esa
información es aproximadamente 7 cual es
la desviación estándar de la población
para estos datos aproxime la respuesta a
la décima más cercana
bueno la desviación estándar de la
población es la media es la medida de
qué tan lejos están en promedio todos
estos datos de la media
eso es la raíz cuadrada del promedio de
la raíz cuadrada del promedio de las
distancias al cuadrado de qué tan lejos
están estos puntos de la media esto
puede sonar algo loco pero ya verán que
cuando lo desarrollamos tendrá más
sentido y los cálculos no son tan
complejos lo primero que vamos a hacer
es calcular la varianza la varianza que
tiene esta anotación y después la
desviación estándar que es la raíz
cuadrada de esto para que tengan una
opción la varianza es igual al promedio
promedio
promedio del cuadrado de las distancias
el cuadrado
dos de las
distancias
distancias a la media
media
ok que se note bien todo esto
esencialmente es qué tan lejos está por
ejemplo el 4 del 7 pues está 3 y esto lo
calculó al cuadrado vamos a calcular
entonces la media es 7 y estas son cada
uno de los puntos tengo que ver la
distancia de cada uno de estos a la
media así que es 4 -7 al cuadrado esto
es igual
la diferencia es menos 3 pero como es al
cuadrado está en 9 las siguientes 13
menos 7 es igual a 6 6 al cuadrado es
igual 36 ahora 5 menos 7 al cuadrado es
menos dos menos 2 al cuadrado es igual a
6 - 7 a 17 medio raro es un 767 es igual
a menos 1 al cuadrado es igual a 1 y
finalmente 9 menos 7 al cuadrado es
igual a 2 al cuadrado es 4
ok
ahora vamos a sumar todo esto 9 36 45 45
449 49 150 50 más 4 son 54 y lo vamos a
dividir entre 5 que son el número de
elementos 54 entre 5 esto es igual a la
varianza y esto es igual a 10 enteros
cuatro quintos
que si los ponemos en decimales va a ser
10.8
esto es la varianza pero nos piden la
desviación estándar de la población que
es la raíz cuadrada de esto hay que 8
tan raro me quedo la desviación estándar
esto es igual a la raíz cuadrada de la
varianza
como ya encontramos la varianza va a ser
igual a la raíz cuadrada de 10.8 en esos
exámenes me parece que no nos dejan
sacar calculadoras y que vamos a más o
menos echarle un ojito para ver qué
valor puede ser este la raíz cuadrada ok
el cuadrado de 33 por 39 que se aproxima
el cuadrado de 44 por 4 16 esto ya no se
aproxima tanto entonces esta desviación
estándar esta raíz va a estar más
aproximada 3 y de las opciones la más
cercana es la 3.3 que es la opción
veamos el siguiente problema
tenemos esta serie de números y nos
dicen que leo encontrar la media y la
desviación estándar del conjunto de
números que se muestran si es una 5 a
cada número cuál de las siguientes
opciones resultará veamos la primera
opción bueno ésta no puede ser ya que si
agregamos 5 a cada número por ejemplo
vamos a hacerlo si yo tengo 3 a esto le
agrego 5
y a esto tengo el 6 de agregó 5 + 2 a
cada uno de estos les estoy agregando 52
más cinco más uno más 5
55 todo esto entre
6 para sacar el promedio esto es lo
mismo que si yo tengo tres más seis más
dos más uno más 7 + 5
entre seis entre seis más
5 x 6 ya que aquí tengo 65 que estoy
sumando que lo mismo que multiplicar 5
por 6
entre 6 estos se cancelan y me va a
quedar
que tenemos esto que es el promedio más
5 no multiplicada por cinco así que esta
primera opción no es vemos la opción 2
en el problema anterior vimos que la
desviación estándar es el promedio de la
distancia hacia la media o hacia el
promedio si desplazamos
todo esto en cinco lugares la media y
todos los números las distancias a la
media no van a cambiar así que la
división estándar no va a cambiar así
que esta opción b tampoco es la opción c
bueno acabamos de ver la media no
cambiará acabamos de ver que si va a
cambiar se le va a incrementar en 5
esta opción se tampoco
y en la última opción pues no dice que
la desviación estándar no va a cambiar
pues la distancia de los números a la
media no va a cambiar por lo tanto el
cuadrado de esa distancia tampoco cambia
entonces la varianza no va a cambiar y
si no cambia la varianza no va a cambiar
la desviación estándar por lo que en
efecto la respuesta correcta es la d